let's see if we can figure out the
surface area of this cereal box and
there's a couple of ways to tackle it
the first way is well let's figure out
the surface area of the sides that we
can see and then think about what the
surface area of the sides that we can't
see are and how they might relate and
then add them all together so let's do
that so the front of the box is 20
centimeters tall and 10 centimeters wide
it's a rectangle so to figure out its
area we can just multiply 20 centimeters
times 10 centimeters and that's going to
give us 200 centimeters 200 centimeters
or 200 square centimeters I should say
200 square centimeters that's the area
of the front and let me write it over
here as well 200 now we also know
there's another side that has the exact
same area as the front of the box and
that's the back of the box and so let's
write another 200 square centimeters for
the back of the box now let's figure out
the area of the top of the box the top
of the box is we see it's 3 the box is 3
centimeters deep so this right over here
is 3 centimeters 3 it's 3 centimeters
deep and it's 10 centimeters wide we see
that the box is 10 centimeters wide so
the top of the box is going to be 3
centimeters times 10 centimeters which
is 30 square centimeters of area so
that's the top of the box 30 square
centimeters
well the bottom of the box is going to
have the exact same area we just can't
see it right now so that's going to be
another 30 and we have 2 more sides
because this box has 6 sides we have
this side panel that is 20 centimeters
tall we see that the height of the box
is 20 centimeters and 3 centimeters deep
so 3 times 3 times 20 3 times let me
write that a little bit neater 3 times
20 that's 20 centimeters right there 3
centimeters times 20 centimeters is
going to give us 60 square centimeters
60 square centimeters now that's this
side panel but there's another side
panel that has the exact same air that's
on the other side of the box so 60
centimeters squared or squared
centimeters for this side and then
another 60 for the corresponding side
opposite to it that we can't see and now
we can just add up all of these together
and so we get 0 let's see this is going
to be
carry the one or regroup the one it's a
100 and then we have 500 so we get 580
square centimeters is the surface area
of this box